if you're taking on debt to go to
college today unless you're going to a
top 3% school you're in deep [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got your prospectus
[Music]
good morning morning thanks for coming
thanks for having me yeah to your place
yes
yeah really cool it's really far from
Montclair New Jersey though I'm aware
yeah but Fred I always get excited when
somebody gets transferred from Hudson
Yards to here and there's II find out
their true grit
definitely so you said today's a good
day because the sun's out yes I like the
Sun I've never not seen you in a good
mood
that's true I'm fairly I'm consistently
in a good mood I have a fairly solid
perspective on what life's about and it
puts me into a pretty good mood but
don't you think the one thing that all
of us entrepreneurs have in common is
being so positive and seeing the glass
full yes I think optimism with practic I
think really successful entrepreneurs
use an incredible concoction of optimism
and practicality right mm-hmm I think I
think the fine line between optimism and
delusion is extremely fascinating and I
do think that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs fail but I couldn't agree
with you more
I'm I'm in the yes business and and that
causes a lot of mistakes but only in the
micro and I think the macro of being in
the yes positive half glass full
business is essential for big big
impacts and successes you knew you were
an entrepreneur at seven yes you didn't
just have a lemonade stand no you had a
lemonade and franchise okay what does
that mean it means I was able to trick
Rob Eterna camera so Byrne and Eric
Godfrey and Michael Bronfman and Andy
Greco into standing behind lemonade
stands while I made signs and put them
on trees and posts okay that was at
seven yes I had a store when I was about
12 with my friends yes it was a great
store in your own home unfortunately was
in the basement so not a lot of foot
traffic and no internet back then but it
was a start I get it I made cool stuff
you tricked people into going downstairs
I did I think my parents yes all those
great customers yeah and how do you
balance okay first of all the first time
I met you I had no idea who you are I'm
like I don't know I came in we had a
meeting I was like meet this person I
meet this person okay took a year I came
in and
I'm an hour I spent it with you I fell
in love instantly I'm like this is the
coolest guy now everybody knows you hmm
I would say about 90% of the people know
you Mickey Drexler didn't know you I'm
like Mickey now Mickey knows you now
Mickey goes into meetings saying to
people do you know Gary Vee what I mean
you don't know Gary Vee
so you're infectious I think positivity
is very real I think that intent is I
think I when I try to psychoanalyze
myself which I do a lot I really do
i I do realize what I'm attracted to and
other people is what people are
attracted to with me it's why I'm
attracted to you I think people that
have good intent and one thing I'm very
positive of is if somebody doesn't need
somebody else or wants something from
somebody else they become unbelievably
infectious and I'm I would say a
weakness of mine is my deep desire to
not need anything from anybody at all
times which makes me unbelievable like
likeable to a lot of people especially
in the long term because I think my
personality and my jersey nough sand my
curse then my bravado especially in
public settings I think sometimes
confuses people at first in the
long-term it really works out I'm very
happy to be charismatic and likeable and
it makes me happy I like people a lot
and more importantly I'm very 5149 I
like the leverage and this is just the
truth
I like the leverage of giving more than
I asked for it's a it's my comfortable
place I
it's my comfortable place but there's
gotta be days where you wake up and say
I don't want to talk to us all
I am tired I am tired I'm exhausted I
need you got it it's like it's yin and
yang you need to recharge sometimes no
no I recharge all I mean I'm very into
recharging what times you get up today
this morning 7:00 Sat 47 okay so you did
not exercise this morning I did from
today you have a trainer I do that comes
every day every day travels with me
that's awesome that was a I've really
gotten interested in
why people that can afford it are more
likely to buy a painting than to buy to
hire somebody full-time to travel with
them and make them healthier I'm
fascinated by this I'm fascinated by
that I don't know things fascinate me
that people wanting to buy things over
buying time convenience or health is
something I'm spending a lot of time
thinking about
that's amazing especially as I'm
entering the health world there's
nothing better than being healthy
there's lighting and by the way jumping
to mental you know back to stress
anxiety things of that nature jumping
from kind of like you know food and and
cardio and things of that nature
I think everybody's different right like
I think everybody needs different things
I know what my strengths and weaknesses
are on the mint on the recharging thing
you know it's really interesting I've
said this before and I think people
gloss over it the New York Jets are a
big refresher for me because when you're
an entrepreneur you know since I've been
22 years old the thing that I probably
take the most pride in is that from the
day I graduated schools from a day I
came home from Mount Ida college to this
second I have been the last stop in the
business that I'm in I am the operator
the buck falls with me and you know this
and anybody listening knows us the level
of anxiety when you have to worry about
everything mm-hmm and now in today's
world with digital the fact that when I
wake up at six forty seven in the
morning the first thing I have to do and
that let me face it's not beer the first
thing I do is I look at my phone and I
have to look at all those texts and
thank god there's no fire in London
thank God nothing you know like right
you know it's it's for me it's like the
scariest things go in order number one
getting a phone call in the middle night
scary right because you're just scared
you're just scared somebody's sick or
dying next is that hundredth of a second
before I look at my phone because I know
I'm gonna look at texts which are only
about fires or issues nobody's texting
me and my 900 ploy is saying like have a
rad day today or like
son is rocking it is this is on fire
this is [ __ ] up this is an issue and
so but then how do you let it go to go
workout with your trainer easily because
I'm in the business of being a
firefighter like it's so funny I
actually think the great comp to an
entrepreneur is a firefighter or a fixer
I think I think I'm a fixer and I guess
like gangster [ __ ] like the fixer like
you're gonna kill somebody
no but if someone's got a problem I
don't care how big or small it is I will
find the answer yeah I think that's
right I you know you are you're the last
line of defense
mhm so what did you eat today nothing
nothing so I'm gonna be fast today
actually the whole day the whole day so
you do intermittent fast I do or you do
more than that no I like doing actually
haven't done in about six or seven
months and I think I blame it for being
up about 7 pounds more than I want to be
it's real good for me I I love it and
literally I just restarted yesterday was
very light I had like four tiny crab
legs I woke up this morning I'm like
yeah like yes like I need it sooner x''k
no isn't an erection when you like throw
up or said there's no that's the limit
only I've got it yeah anorexic just not
eating yeah oh I eat I just don't eat
one day a week so one full day you drink
water that's a problem okay that is
probably like I'm gonna drink something
right now well I'm a camel right I'm
actually it's probably why I'm gonna die
like my situation we first of all biting
it I didn't see it okay good
water and I have a terrible relationship
this is a very Eastern I drink tea this
is a brittle herbal love have a drink
well that's water I know but even that
I'm not drinking enough okay and
honestly it's comfort food I grew up in
a Russian household where tea was around
all the time
I'm looking at Tyler because it's funny
I always have tea and coffee around but
I max out I like two cups or a cup and a
hat like I just need to have it there
like they probably have inside jokes I'd
like there's a tea and then he's not
gonna drink it like it's a it's
literally like a comfort food but but
it's a lifestyle so if you wake up in
the morning and drink two glasses of
water force it down cuz garyvee could do
anything he puts his mind to do that
it'll change your everything about the
way it alarms your metabolism rain
you'll not that you need to think ever
believe where my brain goes I like you
so much
that I'm gonna really try to do this now
only so I can reference your podcast in
public sessions for the next four years
oh I know what why did we like each
other so much I just thought it was me I
think we're very similar yeah I guess
what I think my family's from Belarus
see like I'm not kidding
we're probably related yeah my last name
it's brown Chanel or something no all
right that's not your main every what
remember maiden name is my grandfather
changed his name when he came to horse
because it was like Dimitri blue
ciabatta
he was like brown like you know by the
way really funny thing about having
vaynermedia and like this whole vein or
thing that I'm building every company
with it my dad when he came to America
immigration tried to get him to drop the
Chuck they're like you should be Sasha
Boehner and he was like no I'm
Vaynerchuk oh yeah you should name your
next kid Chuck I wish I could have
another kid my wife is so against it
Oh get me to your wife one more time we
will I am sir I was 41 when I had the
baby who's now 20 [ __ ] to me oh it
was amazing it's exactly nice and I
would I wish I would have done a fourth
oh my one I wish I didn't have that kid
my dad is the most interesting guy on
this issue he's a really kind of like I
call him a cactus cuz he's tough on the
outside but he's real kind of mushy if
you really get to know him his great
regret in life is he promised my mom we
would have five kids I was like the only
thing my mom said they were like 19 in
Russia she's like I want five kids he's
like cool
we had three my mom was 31 when she had
AJ she was a kid still um and my dad was
so scared about paying for college that
he didn't want to have more kids and he
like sits and talks about it all the
time the regret of like but 3 is amazing
I have I've said three yeah threes the
best right and you have two and your
wife is so awesome come on your preacher
and my parents are like you make such
great kids like you need that more I'm
like I'm on board yeah mostly I want to
interview your wife cuz how how what is
it like being married to Gary that is
always on can't go anywhere in public
without you being completely like fanned
over like how does she deal with that
easily she's incredible she's she lives
in her own cocoon I think one thing you
may know is we don't put out content of
her or our kids and so we play that
pretty insular she doesn't give
[ __ ] about any of this like attention
she she's proud of me she knows me so
well and the one of the people that
knows me the best if not the best so she
knows it's coming from a good place so
she likes that but what she is scared
she gets scared she like definitely gets
scared and so that's something I think
about as well but when do you give her
her time like when is it just you and
her like weekends 7 weeks vacation but
the truth is were very much a 1957
couple it is absolutely a little bit of
a divide and conquer and we talked about
that we know that that's something that
may have to evolve but it is definitely
1957 meaning she's a stay-at-home mom
you were can she make sure there's food
on the table well no because I get home
at 11:30 p.m. on you get home at 11:30
every night I got home at 12:30 7:00
last night when do you see your children
I know begins yeah seven weeks vacation
like I'm absolutely not living a
politically correct like - everybody's
work-life balance
standpoint but I'm also unbelievably
unfazed by it because I'm in a depth
versus with conversation in my life and
I'm also in this is this moment right
now and I'm always in a place of
understanding what will I regret how
will I roll and most importantly it's
interesting something Lizzie got me a
plaque that said you know my father
taught me how to live by living you know
and and I think a lot about that I think
I think a lot about like what check
boxes do I want to check and for whom
the most fascinating thing to go out you
know one of the reasons I love when the
four of us went out to dinner I remember
when we left I was like see that's the
people we kind of need to hang out with
because what's so interesting to have
dinner with couples and that was my
husband and my and and with Gary and you
know that yep
is is everybody's just judging everybody
like the amount of six person dinners I
go to and like people like what you're
supposed to do this and your suppose I'm
like I'm like you don't know anything
about anything like I don't want to
judge you know I I put out a lot of
opinions but they're macro they're not
2d rock they're to the general public
but I have nothing for anybody on an
individual basis unless they ask I have
no interest in
judging people's relationships or how
they raised our kids or things of that
nature and I'm fascinated by how many
people like doing that then what are you
curious about everything I'm
unbelievably curious about how people
make decisions no question which makes
me then curious about almost everything
communication right so hence Manor like
I'm very fascinated by what gets people
to do things inspires him to do things
makes him not do things calms you know
I'm a boy that was born in the Soviet
Union that came to America in the 80s
I'm unbelievably I think affected by
that when it comes to communication the
fact that my mom wrote a book report
that she thought the del Castro was the
bravest man in the world like blows my
mind I'm like wow and then you know so
much of what's happening in the
political climate now and with the
internet and things that nature my life
has always circled around communication
do you ever think of yourself at 70 a
lot and what do you think you'll be
doing at 70 working a lot um enjoying
enjoying a very similar version of what
I am now enjoying whatever that may be
my intuition is that I will evolve into
other things that excite me and interest
me around communication you know I'm
quiet about my nonprofit work or some of
the other stuff I do well could you tell
me about it then what's your nonprofit
so I I'm on the board of pencils of
promise mm-hmm I'm a well member at
charity water and I'm I'm laughing
because I see Tyler over me I'm
unbelievably fascinated by this people
that donate to causes or sit on boards
but then don't help acquaintances or
slight family members or friends in
times of need so my buckets break into
I'm very passionate about charity water
and pets as a promise because they were
founded and run and not run any more on
pencil promise but they at the time when
I joined them they were founded and run
by young individuals that were treating
them more like startups than NGOs and I
love the whole like 80 percent the money
wasn't going to like the executives of
it and people weren't on the board
because they just wanted to rub elbows
with other important all the things I
became like oh my god this is what
out so that was exciting but the third
bucket for me is I'm unbelievably
passionate about helping people that I
even slight leave met three times when
they have cancer or they're how like I'm
looking again I'm looking at Tyler cuz
he knows this is a something I've never
said mildly the most interesting thing
about how I think about it is I feel
guilty to only do macro things like cure
the water issue in Africa when somebody
I've had dinner with three times around
business it has a GoFundMe cuz she has
breast cancer like I'm like [ __ ] I have
to give to that like what the hell like
well I don't want to be idealized like
people love to do things for their
public person the reason I don't talk
about nonprofit is cuz I watch all my
other friends use it to tell the world
that they're a good person well I don't
mind talking about if it's gonna do some
guy gray so we started a thing called
reaching out Montclair yes this just
helps the underserved among Claire it
will never go outside of New Jersey and
we see it first on we got kids costumes
this weekend we had authors come and
read books it's you know we breathable
mattresses and then I'll clears an
interesting comp monk clear and and some
it has this and other very fascinated by
towns that really have the quote-unquote
other side of the tracks it's a very
it's a very micro dynamic that what I
loved about when I saw that I looked at
it for a few minutes I look at nothing
I mean who I like that because I was
always weirded out by the extrude you
know I did so much direct mail for Wine
Library when I was building that store
in New Jersey I know everything about
every ZIP code in New Jersey and so like
I like
it's so funny when I meet people they're
like oh I'm from Bergen I'm like which
town and then because they don't and I'm
like I know that I'm like a hundred
thirteen medium income like I know stuff
about Jersey and summit Montclair couple
other places they're fascinating to me
Westfield where you have like these big
micro climates you know I'm using wine
terminology where like this sign is like
homes that are million and that side is
really not and our kids all go to school
in the same place my kids went to public
school which oh by the way is amazing
yeah and just the greatest thing for the
kids on the good side of Montclair high
to Stanford the first kid loved it you
know so school's broken in America
random quick take it's so [ __ ] broken
that I can't breathe like it's so broken
doodoo does anybody understand the world
we actually live in yes well I think
college is the is the worst thing in the
world that kids can't afford to go to
college if you look you need to start a
college you need to start a college I
think that would probably be the ER
legacy I'm gonna sign now I'm definitely
know it's funny when you said seventy
I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] up college it
ran through my mind uh here's what I
would say you didn't graduate or you did
yes I did but I but I put them out I to
college like I mean that what what's
wrong with it literally the mic that
we're talking into could get admitted to
met like there isn't like literally if
you're all dead people can get into
Mount Ida college actually Mount Ida
college went out of business recently
this is a fun fact literally went out of
business after 100 plus 200 years
I think UMass Amherst's like absorbed it
what's wrong with it
I played Madden for 98 percent of my
college experience you got an A in
Madden so that's good I went to Emerson
College I showed up the day before with
my transcripts they let me in they said
what do you want to major in
I said make up they said okay I said you
have a makeup program they said no I
said alright I'll make it up and I went
to Emerson now you can't get into
Emerson I know now it's a tough school
yeah you know honestly like so don't be
embarrassed by my berries nobody
propagandas in more than me I post my
report card with a - 47 out of 250 one
cut the only thing I'm proud of in my
life is that I'm a [ __ ] student that I
[ __ ] spit in the face of the system
when nobody else was doing it back then
but it is not gonna work for all the
other kids that are listening out there
it's it's your journey it's not gonna be
someone else's journey that's right in
the clarity that I always want to say
about colleges like look if you want to
work at Goldman Sachs you better get
good ass grades and you better go to
like Wharton you better go to Harvard
like you have to know yourself and know
what you want if you're an entrepreneur
right if you truly are and here's the
scariest scenario with education in
America today you're an entrepreneur and
you're passionate about it and you want
you can't breathe if you don't do it and
you're okay if you make 80,000 a year
selling pillows or you go and build
like did it and your parents make you
take on debt to go to a shitty college
cuz they want to feel good that you went
to college to their other friends that
to me is scary as [ __ ] but everyone has
different stories in different journeys
see this girl right here yes she when I
left Bobbi Brown cosmetics I went to the
Apple store I had three hours of work
there she was such a rock star yes I
hired her she's gone to a two-year
college yes she I don't know where you
would have been if I didn't like pick
you up that she would be at vaynermedia
running the company
well she now is like everything and does
all of our content that's right yeah so
I mean d-roc homeschooled like I don't
know we're tough like like it's all the
same [ __ ] Tyler's a dope all the time
guys from Montclair high yeah but he's a
dope I mean come on like the world
listen every winner that I like dope I'm
the biggest dope of them all like my
definition of like the reality is the
world changed college was built to
create workers for an environment that
was much more mapped to 1959 and that's
wonderful and it was a great era and
Mazel Tov and all good but guess what if
you're taking on debt to go to college
today unless you're going to a top 3%
school you're in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] so
why can't we have a college that the
kids are actually entrepreneurs the hold
on to oh this is gonna happen but then
what I think you and Richard Baker have
to do that together because I think
people should stop telling people what
to do you should do it
no I'm I know this is more of a Gary
thing I'm sorry
right look I think you looked I think
what's actually happening is it's
already happening without people
realizing it meaning one of the things
that I'm most excited about the content
that I put out especially on Instagram
cuz it skews young at least for now it's
obviously aging up quickly which is
amazing
you're changing people stop I was on a
FaceTime with a woman in India yesterday
on snapchat because she Tyler she wanted
like what happened or did I see her on
Twitter what happened she won I was on a
seven minute FaceTime yesterday with a
woman who was sitting in India telling
me that she has to decide between go
to Australia for school or staying in
India for two more years because she
wants to get an Indian's citizenship
because she's got a Pakistani
citizenship and she wants to be
discriminated against a little less hmm
it was really powerful as you can
imagine and I'm sitting I'm just
thinking about all these things I'm like
we live in a world where I'm in a car
right now talking on FaceTime through
snapchat with a young woman in India
where my words are about to impact her
making a life decision you want to talk
about pretty crazy it's super crazy
nobody's making that like that's not
something Star Trek or Star Wars thought
about when they were making up what the
world would look like in 2018
they thought about flying cars they
[ __ ] up but all this others internet
stuff we didn't know and so the ground
rules of our society are changing
remarkably which is your favorite
platform um mine is Instagram because
I'm a visual person you know what's
funny I'm unbelievably native to Twitter
because I love community management I
love engaging with people and Twitter so
easy to do that I can just see them all
in that format um you know instagrams
been remark you know to the to the very
nice comment that you made of like
people now knowing who I am no question
Instagram podcast and YouTube's from two
years three years ago when I really made
a commitment there you know if I had to
pick a favor if I if you said to me
you've got to keep one I would keep
Instagram right now because the number
one asset that I chase is people's
attention and that is where it is and so
that's why I would have to pick that and
I heard yesterday that John Mayer the
John Mayer has a new talk show on
Instagram that's awesome I thought that
was available never thought of that yeah
John Mayer my favorite guy awesome yeah
I love that dude yeah he's super smart
like super creatively interesting like
one of the more interesting people I've
sat down with in the last like ten years
like just an interesting dude how come
he's not married as kids I you know I
don't know him well enough to even take
a guess but I know that how he thinks
about creativity and attention and
communication which is the foundation of
the kind of long conversation we had I
think he really understands and who have
you not met that you're dying to get on
your show or talk to
you know it's funny I don't get it I
don't know why that doesn't like that
was that's hard for me answered the only
person I ever wish I'd met that I didn't
that I never will be able to as Randy
the Macho Man Savage that's devastating
to me I would have liked to get that at
bat okay I'm so sorry I don't know who
that is
all right let's cancel listen thanks for
having me he's the greatest [ __ ]
wrestler of all time okay
I had a wrestler at my sweet 16 who I
don't know two women wrestlers my papa's
whine about it for me I don't know I'm
from Chicago I don't know who was Papa
Sam got him as entertainment that's how
they wrestled they wrestled two women
wrestlers
I don't Papa knew someone that knew
someone and they came yes so good yeah
so no sorry I didn't know your wrestler
friend but I love how everybody now like
gets Drake but you had two women
wrestlers I actually went to a bar
mitzva Drake performed I believe before
he was Drake
I got it he referenced it I know we're
talking about um nobody nobody nobody
that's just that's the actual truth
meaning how about your dad have you ever
gotten your dad I know I have and it's
really good we'll meet my dad Jam it's
really good I really like it and I'll be
honest with you I like it for one reason
only that my great great grandkids are
gonna watch it I'm obsessed with people
not understanding what's actually
happening which is that everybody that's
living right now is gonna actually be
the patriarch and matriarch of their
families in perpetuity because the most
content is gonna be created about us so
that in 400 years we're gonna be the
starting point of our families because
our great grandparents and our parents
and our great-great grandparents there's
some random pictures but with us there's
gonna be like unlimited content yeah
that's pretty cool I think it's very
cool so you give advice all the time if
there's one thing you could tell people
right now to do right now that will
change the course of their life one
thing communicate the poison that's in
their head to the person that needs to
hear it
tell me more every single person
listening has something to say to
somebody they love very much that is
boss bothering the [ __ ] out of them do
you do that yeah you let it go
you tell it's how it's it's why I only
give advice I take mm-hmm the the reason
I'm in such a happy place is I over
communicate even
when it's uncomfortable and that has
taken me a long I run in pockets I do a
very bad job of it with people that I'm
still trying to get to a place employees
I'm really bad with radical candor I've
gotten dramatically better but I'm I'm
not as good as I can be
cuz I'm still optimistic that I can get
them into a place of self-awareness or
output that will make them successful
you know you know who I would have been
hmm
I would have absolutely been the young
teenage girl that always chased the bad
boy thinking that I could get him to a
good place that is absolutely my DNA and
then you picked the most perfect normal
woman you could find yes yes that's very
telling
I like that so you've got a normal side
under your Gary Venus I'm unbelievably
normal which people don't believe her I
saw that in you the first time I am a
tortoise in a hares costume okay let's
take me a second to my and my energy and
personality confuse the [ __ ] out of
people because they shouldn't spend the
time figuring me out but the people that
are closest to me or the other no are
completely the other way cuz they know
who I am
they're always around me you can't hide
so yeah I would say I think I'm the most
normal like I'm out and I and this is a
funny statement but let me say where I'm
actually going with it
I'm dramatically practical I'm I'm I'm
I'm most comfortable when I'm in
business I don't go to things like it's
so funny when I go to a public thing
especially over the last year or two
where I think more people know who I am
since you've blown up he's people say
people freaked out
not because I'm cool it's cuz I'm never
out like it's just supply-and-demand
like when I go to a public thing it's
like I'm just never out I'm literally
like last night I got home at 12:37
because I was in seven different
meetings between 7 p.m.
like that's and when you got home did
you get in bed and go to sleep or do you
need to wind down at night like luckily
Lizzie like you know Lizzie and I hung
and chatted for 15 minutes I waited up
for you yeah she waits
for me a lot oh my god that woman she's
all mine
oh my god yeah that's pretty awesome do
you think you'll be the dad that shows
up at all the games no you don't think
so but I show up at a ton of stuff like
again I'm just looking at these over
your shoulder at the Montclair mafia and
he knows all the truth we fight like
hell to be at everything but upon your
kids things do you think you'll be the
teachers conferences we fight like hell
to be at everything but if I I've booked
a speech for April 14th or my birthday
you cannot do that that was the moment
of the show I love that [ __ ] by the way
I'm not even sure if I've actually
booked a meeting free but that is
everything I know which is what makes
the whole thing very kismet but I
definitely have a keynote somewhere in
that range
and you know like I don't know I'm
getting heavily compensated it's locked
in
I can't bail if tomorrow if on February
19th Lizzie emails me and Tyler and Alex
and says to us hey Gary needs to be at
this recital on April 14th and then
Tyler has to write the scary email of
like oh [ __ ] he's in San Francisco and
then well then I'll tell you what you
have to do you have to go into the
principal the first day and say dude
give me all the dates I put them in my
calendar and I don't book a speech on
the date we do lock in yeah we do lock
that in but obviously as you know things
pop up and ask it changed snow days and
all that horseshit plus these private
school kids don't even go to [ __ ]
school like that by the way that's the
racket
these [ __ ] don't go - first of all
they should start private school on
October 1st because literally between
[ __ ] Jewish holidays and all this
other [ __ ] they're literally in school
three days in September so send your
kids to public school
I'm Montclair I'm thrilled I'm not
moving in Montclair I know oh my god
this is actually a brand I think I told
you this first time we go now you know
this Tyler I always thought I was gonna
live in Montclair Upper Montclair Upper
Montclair Montclair is kind of different
I just know it based on his head thing I
cuz I had the store in Springfield
Milburn and I was like I want to live in
Short Hills to close this store like I
needed I wanted to have a little commute
mm-hm I wanted to have like a little 15
minutes listen to like some sports radio
in the morning but if I went randomly
just picked and Mendham used to be on my
mind too but I didn't have whoring if I
didn't have the commute that hour or two
hours a day I've written nine books and
I don't know how to
I do it in the backseat of a car I could
do everything in the backseat of a car I
can't do it totally understand I've I've
got I've done a simple I can't write I
can't put a sentence together and I've
written six books right so when do you
do it
I do I know when I do verbal and so me
and stuff i I I have a ghostwriter
Stephanie land who's incredible and we
literally go into a cocoon like a room
like this for a day or two and I just
talk until the end okay first of all I
just heard about your new show and it
sounds unbelievable unbelievable so tell
us how trash talk came and you don't
really need the cash I don't think so no
I what drives your Saturday to make $613
um what's driving me is two things
happiness is the ROI
I know but on this trash talk
I'm not sure if there's any place I'm
happier in the world then when I am
actively garage saling in New Jersey at
8:13 in the morning on a Saturday uh I
am really jet it's scary how close
garage saleing is to the Jets and I
would actually like I'm gonna have to
you know I want to be authentic I'm
starting to even ask myself questions of
like no no the jet the Jets are number
one because I'm just thinking like what
if what if the best garage sales were
only on Sunday I would go to the jet so
Jets are number one and this is like
selfish stuff like like putting family
on a complete pedestal like those seven
weeks are the engine that drive my life
but on a selfish kick garage saling like
it's like going to verona the other day
which is I know close by yes going to
Verona and like going into people's like
garages and you know driveways it and
then oh once in a while you can go in
the house that's when [ __ ] gets crazy
cuz I'm just trying to buy everything
like I love garage here's what's really
driving me in this explosion an enormous
amount of people follow me who
disproportionally are affected by making
a hundred to five hundred dollars more a
month like that means is something for
real
all of my homies and contemporaries are
telling these people to build the next
Facebook I'm practical I know that
anybody who's listening right now who
genuinely needs an extra hundred bucks a
week the easiest and I don't use by the
way I hate the word easy the easiest way
to make a hundred bucks extra a week is
to go to thrift stores goodwill garage
sales buy things and sell them on ebay
offer up face book marketplace like a
real real there's so many places it's so
scary like I actually believe most
people can make between 50 to 100
thousand dollars if they're average at
it when I think about all the people
making 37k a year when I think about all
the people grinding to jobs working at
Best Buy overnight and something else
during the day and they're collectively
making 13 bucks an hour it's just real
who could instead garage sale and go to
Goodwill buy and flip [ __ ] on eBay or in
addition or in addition but when you're
working to jot like but but honestly
Bobby you'll appreciate this it's back
to practicality or here's my big thing
just try it for a little while see if
you can do it I do think that the
average skilled person after a couple
months gets to twenty or thirty bucks an
hour
Jenna read the book nickel and dimed no
but it sounds exciting it's well it's
about people that actually live their
life as waitresses and working at
Walmart and ya know it's its own people
- no it's just it's unbelievable how
hard it is and God forbid someone gets
sick and God forbid oh you know the
state or tire blows right listen the
great thing of going to Mount Ida
college is ninety seven percent of my
friends and contemporaries and
classmates were in awfully bad
situations like welfare like bad bad -
great things happen one I
disproportionally collected a lot of
swag and - it gave me perspective that
is unbelievably uncomfortable and what I
know is I'm passionate about this
because I'm showing people how to fish
and it's working
are you still friends with anyone you
went to college with yeah yeah Tokyo Joe
moose okay
la you're I'm on this incredible thread
where like every time we I mean we
literally talk ironically we literally
talk football like it's unbelievable how
much smack talk goes on in there that's
so cool you you could tell a lot by by
someone by being friends with their
friends I couldn't agree more
well talk to me about the shoes cuz I'm
very excited to wear mine once I get the
right size I think they're so cool by
the way this is my color the blue it's
the Caribbean I'm still waiting for you
to come to my house yes sweet um I my
number one thesis in business is that
nostalgia is underpriced obsessed with
it
like I believe and I think Marvel you
know proved it by taking IP and
reforming it and so I'm very excited
about doing those kind of things in the
future of my career and no question the
most significant test case of my thesis
has been this collaboration I did with
k-swiss where literally there's a Gary
Vee shoe right like I'm taking my shoe
off because I get so excited when I see
this my signature is on a shoe that is
anodyne Chris in the bottom of yes we
talk about families should have dropped
my shoes I want you to actually really
sign them and so Bobbi it's really cool
because you know for you and I unlike
these kids that are in the room here we
may remember a time where k-swiss had a
whole you know pre nike okay if you
google k-swiss like like culture if you
type k-swiss 1980s you'll see pictures
of ice-t Mike Tyson dr. gray they were
really so for me when I was young and
affected by yo MTV raps and the culture
and Edison had great diversity and so I
was very into you know kind of early
hip-hop man k-swiss was cool like I wore
my case West on the first date of fifth
grade like I made it and and then they
weren't cool for a very long time and so
to reboot it as an entrepreneurial
sneaker for me to have the kind of
strategy in what I've done with
influencer marketing and marketing with
it to watch it now be a thing that is
popping a little bit not only my
sneakers but the whole brand and it's
been really a great business case study
where it's been great to reward Barney
and the people of k-swiss who took a
chance on me who signed me to the D
maybe before this pop moment so they
obviously that worked out the whole
thing's great like watching Barney like
run around and like do keynotes and
things that nature of like how it's been
fun and Patrick and the whole team and
the whole the whole situations been fun
Tyler
we keep referencing him as a nice
Montclair boy boy has been deeply
involved in it it's been fun for him to
like hat you know who loves sneakers in
that culture to have say in design or
distribution so it's been a great thing
for my team it's been a great thing I
mean but I always say things like would
nine-year-old me I love that game right
like nine-year-old me if you told
nine-year-old me that I had a sneaker
with my signature on it I would have
laughed you out of the room I'm working
on a deal right now do I have that call
this week I'm working on the deal right
now I'm not telling you but I'm working
on deal right now that really the
nine-year-old me you would be like get
the [ __ ] out of here you're buying the
Jets nope no but by the way you don't
worry about that hmm that's the only
thing that feels normal is buying the
Jets I once told it when AJ and I got so
he got courtside seats to the next
couple years ago and we sat there and we
looked at each other I looked at him
like man I saw nothing in between
scrappy immigrant boy and buying the
Jets all the [ __ ] in the middle like
fancy people inviting me to Baker's Bay
I'm being serious
like like Nick's like sneak all of it
the nice soft saw none of it like even
like make fun of myself of like how did
you think it was gonna go down like like
literally make fun of myself when I talk
to myself like that's how it at like you
don't just go for like like we're gonna
win the lottery like I didn't see my
life I didn't see all the neat things
I'm also not into you know d-roc said
something to me the other day about the
process versus things or like the things
that the things get u-verse like he was
like telling me basically like man it
was just a very honest moment he
obviously follows me around all the
times in a unique moment we're in in
Australia and he was like man people
just don't understand how you live your
life like I don't like stuff even like I
like experiences and that's why the
Baker is staying or next thing I get
pumped about but like stuff I don't like
or and even experiences I'm not even
sure how much I really like but we don't
have time I like the process I like the
game I
competing I like inspiring I like I live
for the DMS of like look I got a crazy
DM just back to trash talk like [ __ ]
I want everybody here this I got a DM
from a woman that the DM starts with
I've been a prostitute for the last 12
years of my life and in the last week is
the first time I've ever felt that I
don't have to do this profession anymore
because I've made a couple thousand
dollars buying t-shirt an act for
fashion and I've been going to thrift
stores after your trash talk stuff and
buying clothes and selling it and I've
made so much money like [ __ ] everything
I ever do did you answer her I didn't
cuz like sometimes I get some of those
weird things - it was super I felt super
comfortable answering you know I wasn't
worried like the answer cuz the price
like I wasn't worried about that I
didn't I'm just gonna tell you the truth
probably because I said [ __ ] everything
I ever do in my life like it took me
into such a place of happiness hmm I'm
like yeah like do you know many people
live their entire life never inspiring
anybody for good including their
children well you know what makes me
happy what drink this whole thing down
while we're sitting here - [ __ ] no
problem okay Gary is now drinking my
water literally rather right now put a
boulder on my back and walk to
Afghanistan drink this bottle of water
cuz I want you to go out and while
you're in the car stayed here guys huh
my headache just went away oh I could do
more than ever today you never was here
like one time I got one it was a hey
like hey wife like a what's this feeling
she's like you have a [ __ ] headache
weird it was super weird I was like I
never get headaches okay finish the
water and then my favorite hydration is
my strength
oh that's impossible and your skin is
good yes it's impossible yes no it's
impossible no I know I'm the title by
the way I genuinely believe this is true
I genuinely think the great demise of my
entire like empire is gonna be water no
one I see a Gary Vee water coming out
I'm just sayin opportunity alright you
did a better job
yay well Gary thanks so much for being
on my show that's really but it's really
your show because how much time do we
have I just don't I always think I'm
what about eighth place trophies eighth
place eighth eighth place trophies what
you get no no do you like in Montclair
are they giving like trophies to like
fourth place teams like you sir welcome
yes
what do you know I've been confused by
this week oh my god I'm looking if you
know Gretchen's grandfather was a guy
named Yogi Berra that's [ __ ] amazing
yeah Montclair guys see Montclair guy
she she was my assistant Eddie when she
was a young girl she was the first girl
I ever brought to take your daughter to
work day
Gretchen Berra now she is I don't even
have a title she does so much with hum
present yeah she does but this you know
it's actually I am let's super cool that
you transition to like one of the great
athletes of all time I am fascinated but
like I'm so positive that America is in
deep [ __ ] like nothing is more obvious
to me than when you create entitlement
it's all over as a matter of fact let's
be let's talk about transparency the
great vulnerability of vaynermedia it's
nine years was two three years ago when
I had to wake up and say [ __ ] I care
about feelings and culture and empathy
so much
I've quietly created entitlement here
where merit isn't put on a pedestal
where being kind is but you kind of suck
at your job and I have a lot of work to
do over the next three years to fix this
but when it comes to sports and
especially when you're a kid I mean
being a mom that watched my kids and all
the different sports and yes if you get
fourth place and fits whatever place
it's it's a little bit of a confidence
builder it's like okay I'm out of here
okay Bob you have to Bob here's some
like you know chubby fat kid who's like
bear who naked who needs to understand
yo chubby fat kid you're not gonna be a
professional [ __ ] athlete go be a
great-lookin are you rain I don't give a
[ __ ] you're in pain Marty the fat-ass
you're gonna be a great chef but get the
[ __ ] off the football field you suck but
I just think everyone's good at
something that's right so get off the
[ __ ] football field but guess what
mommy Bobby over here tricking you and
making you think you might be okay no oh
yeah
yes is his microphone louder than mine
or does he just talk loud I'm trying to
figure this out here like you're a
[ __ ] gangster winner and this is why
this is what I'm worried about
but I'm compassionate you got me into
water I'm getting you into like your
Chari
you keep 5th place truck Bobby there's a
reason that people are struggling
mentally and I'm telling you everybody
wants to blame social media it's
[ __ ] it's parents creating fake
environments for children we're building
zoo animals these [ __ ] kids are zoo
animals explain that zoo animals that
we're watching them like what does that
mean it means when you take a tiger from
the Bronx Zoo and yeah put it in the
actual jungle he [ __ ] or she dies in
one second because they've not grown up
in the actual environment you take kids
who [ __ ] think they're good at
baseball because in Montclair up until
[ __ ] 12th grade everybody's [ __ ]
good and then you actually go and play
baseball and you get [ __ ] struck out
nine hundred times in a row but you go
back to your dorm room and start doing
[ __ ] cocaine oh come on Gary it
doesn't work like that that's exactly it
does not my whoa listen listen you look
at the kids faces hi baseball no
football okay he did [ __ ] cocaine but
you know at one point you're like okay
this was really cool and fun all right
this isn't gonna work
no because mommy tricked me because we
had [ __ ] like sundaes after losing 31
to nothing but we may pretend we didn't
keep score guess what
what know if you're not good at football
and you love the sport so go work for
the team like there's ways to take your
passion keep building no but it's true I
mean I watch my kids I had a I had a you
know pro golfer I had you know I had
guys kids that were good at different
things and then they weren't anymore you
know they entered high school you know
they were on traveling soccer and
baseball their entire careers until they
went to high school they realized
they're not gonna make it but I didn't
so they moved on that's fine and listen
a lot of people don't move on yeah and
and creating fake environments is an
issue that needs to be talked about much
more and I think you should create a
fake environment school but the the
fourth place and the eighth place kid
you don't know what you're gonna
encourage him so maybe the next season
he'll be in third place like there's
ways to get
no fake environments don't be don't
doesn't mean like mean it means just
don't create delusion I mean look I and
I teach and I empower young
entrepreneurs girls makeup artists to
come to me and everyone in their uncle
now besides having a media platform and
a podcast once it has a makeup line
that's right so you know I'm I give
everyone advice and the advices be
different have a point of difference and
every day of your [ __ ] life you have
to work mommy we really have our very
serious note like straight no [ __ ]
this is gonna be the best part of the
podcast what percentage of the people
that you meet that tell you they're
gonna start a makeup line do you this is
one that's one of you may be wrong you
may be right I'm just curious what
percentage do you think will actually
have a successful business that you know
whether it has an exit or it pays for
their livelihood like a true successful
business well I think it's very low for
sure it's very low but what is success I
mean when I left it was a billion
dollars that is not normal no no that's
success to me as they get to do it right
and they can like live their life
perfect the number one thing I'm trying
to like and I know my team is seeing me
start to go in this direction I'm
starting to get interested about
expenses not how much you make my big
thing is that success is if you want it
to be the eye shadow king or queen like
that's a great life you like you love
eyeshadow you want to live forever being
doing this eyeshadow thing by the way I
think you could make a hundred nine
thousand dollars a year in profit and
actually be a success well I because in
profit number one I don't believe in
investment right you heard what I said
yeah if you make one hundred nine
thousand dollars in profit by creating
an eye shadow and selling it on Shopify
at eBay and you live in a household and
and your expenses equal eighty eight
thousand for the year you're gonna win
the problem is everybody wants a [ __ ]
BMW and everybody [ __ ] wants to buy
eight thousand dollar handbags and
everybody [ __ ] lives on credit and
overextends themselves an overlap you
know why you and I like profit because
we know that the next economic downturn
all these businesses that everybody
thinks are doing well are gonna go out
of business well I have so many of my
friends that are like wanting to hand me
millions of dollars their venture guys
yes to start new businesses and I'm like
no I don't first of all I don't you know
besides that I think it's ridiculous to
spend more money than
have Bobby of course they want to give
you money their lives are about raising
capital taking a percentage of it and
then giving it to people that actually
do [ __ ]
and then I and one of them told me I
never even have to worry about making a
profit and I'm like that's all I know
how to do is make profits I want to kill
everybody no you don't know you're
positive I must like I'm like a business
athlete when I say I want to kill
everybody I'm like the athlete that
plays on the field and I want to do
everything dirty and get away with it to
win the game right as soon as the game
is over I want to shake your hand and
tell you ask you how your wife's doing
and like like donate to your charity but
on the field I want to kill everybody
and so I think that is something I need
to create more clarity of a lot of the
alpha competitive I want to destroy
everybody's face that's kind of business
that's like when I'm in the game you're
like that
100% when up went back in the day when a
buyer didn't buy something you walked
out any look I'm gonna [ __ ] kill her
no I would just say why tell me why and
I said let me tell you why I think it's
so good and they'd say okay when she was
at a meal and I had a big mistake walk
out be like I'm gonna destroy Karen
right but you know I'm still in the game
I know your son I still have a couple
businesses that are about to blow up I
feel like you know rising like a phoenix
a phoenix yeah no well first of all I
think being on your show that one time
was like oh my god all these like random
people that I've haven't talked to her
seen in years or like oh my god you know
Gary Vee I wanted a a young people want
an introduction which I have never once
said well only once just an intern I
know but that was about it I'm so
flattered when I hear this [ __ ] like
it's I really wish people could feel
flattered more often I you know I'm very
good at giving compliments I like
razzing my teammates um out of love but
I love giving compliments cuz it's so
nice why can't we make that more cool
like that's a cool new agenda that might
be the best part of this we need to get
better I love it I'm so funny at it like
right now like I love telling people
like I'm gonna love your yellow coat
like in the airport and people like
freak out it's the nicest thing we're
just like light people smiling like I
always tell women that creativity louder
what I always stop with when I say oh my
god you're so pretty and they look at me
I'm like well I'm Bobby Brown it's like
I'm not trying to pick you up yeah if I
you know like I like I do
dudes like obviously like you need to be
careful in like even not in this
political climate II always want to be
respectful it's not even careful that's
the wrong word but I love doing it to
dudes I love telling Tyler when he has a
good haircut which by the way I've never
done which means he's never had a good
haircut but we're still hoping oh I just
think it's so crazy Tyler I knew when he
was a little kid it's just crazy
it's just crazy he's gonna be something
he really is you know what's funny
Tyler's very motivating for me because
when he came to me you know he aged a
and him live you know but like watching
time this by the way this is a joke on
Tyler because every admin assistant
every team member watching people
realize they can do so much more is one
of the most intoxicating things for me
of being a manager I don't think people
realize how much [ __ ] they can fit in a
day but did you you didn't just hire him
to be your second-in-command
Heilig slashed him through an
introduction from a great guy Mickey
cloud who runs her Chattanooga office
and he was back then we were doing a lot
of community management you would reply
on Twitter as a brand then AJ needed an
admin and you know Tyler so Carrie you
know Tyler like again he's a dope but
he's so charismatic he wins so he's so
charismatic so somehow it hits a J's
radar so he's interested the best story
of all time and Tyler knows where I'm
about to go
Tyler's day one this is real day one
Tyler is my brother's admin which means
he's in his inbox we get an email from
New York Jets which is a client which
you can imagine I'm so in love with and
literally the email says hey AJ I'd like
to schedule a call I'd like to request
Tyler Schmidt be removed from the Jets
account uh why cuz he stinks guys the
dope I could try to tell you the same
reason I got these and F's this you've
got of players in positions to succeed
if you were an entrepreneur you run a
business or you're a manager
you work for everybody else and you're
number one job in the world is to put
other people in a play in a place to
succeed predicated on their skills and
passion overlay but I think the most
important thing for all of us dopes that
didn't get good grades in school is to
figure out what we're not good at and
tried to work around it get someone else
to do I don't agree more I never learned
how to type and I've written nine books
I'm so I mean there's so many of those
things I'm I'm the greatest [ __ ]
public speaker
the world and if you asked me to read
this in front of this room I would
shiver like like I can't read you could
you just choose not to like anyway do
you read books no no I've written more
books that I've read so are you a DD or
OCD probably I'm both
I mean I'm self diagnosed I have no
interest in letting anybody arbitrarily
like diagnose me they can keep that in
their pocket I'm me I'm intuitive to
like what makes me happy and I keep
trying to become a better version of
that every day and then I try to over
articulate that so that it might impact
somebody else because there is nothing
that feels better than admiration I live
for admiration and and speaking of
admiration the way I actually first
heard about you I just remembered in the
backyard of my house when I was in the
Jersey Shore there were these kids
playing spike ball I went up to this one
kid and I said let me talk to about your
eyebrows it was me oh it's such a good
looking I want to hook up with him but
his eyebrows like now pass because
eyebrows need to be addressed and and he
said you got to come in and meet my boss
and I googled you and I'm like who
I never heard I'm like who and it took
me a year when I came in we talked for
an hour and the next day I found out you
filmed me I remember like John I called
Nick he's like where did you expect I'm
like I didn't know that so I thought I
didn't gonna blush with all the huge Jam
I did not I was so focused on you I did
not see a camera a thing I do not guys
everybody listening to this podcast bad
always loses promise we've been around a
long [ __ ] time it doesn't feel like
that way I promise but something we have
to wait a long time like yes
eight years sure years sure six you know
there's all sorts of numbers yeah all
right we're out of here see okay bye
[Music]
you